mutants Multiverse or fake outs and good
guys gone bad Marvel's phase 4 has
really kept fans on their toes
Evan Peters played quicksilver in the
fox produced X-Men films which prior to
2021 have been disconnected from the MCU
timeline but that all seemed to change
however when Peter showed up on Wanda's
doorstep in one division previously the
mcu's Quicksilver was played by Aaron
Taylor-Johnson and the character was
killed off in the line of duty during
Avengers Age of Ultron the appearance of
pizzas sent Marvel funds speculating
wildly the character's appearance as
Wanda's brother Pietro seemingly opened
the floodgates of the Multiverse and
perhaps indicated that X-Men actors such
as Patrick Stewart and Hugh Jackman
could also show up so was Peter's
playing the Taylor Johnson version of
quicksilver who had somehow been
resurrected or was he a visitor from an
alternate universe thus making the X-Men
films tangentially Canon to the MCU most
of this speculation would ultimately be
squashed as Peter's character in the
show was revealed to be a random
Westview citizen named Ralph boner cast
by Agatha Hawkins to pretend to be
Wanda's brother this McGuffin may have
ultimately proven anti-climactic it
yielded some wild theories and may have
been a non-too subtle foreshadowing of
the chaos to come
Simon Bucky found themselves reunited
with Sharon Carter and the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier a criminal in the
eyes of the American government because
she assisted Captain America during the
events of Civil War Sharon was now
living in madrabor meanwhile throughout
the series there was constant mention of
a mysterious power broker Who Sold
access to superpowers to anyone who
could pay and ruled madropor's
Underworld the figure was heavily
involved in madrabor's business and
sounded like a potential big bad Our
Heroes would eventually face but
although Sharon appeared to be aiding
salmon Bucky throughout the series she
would eventually be revealed as a power
broker herself leading to a number of
follow-up questions yet to be answered
in the MCU then in a post-credits scene
for the series Casa was seemingly
pardoned for aiding Captain America by
the U.S government and reinstated as an
agent but as we saw shortly afterward
she's still maintaining her identity as
the power broker the intricate web of
Sharon Carter's true intentions and what
may have led to this 108 allegiances
continues to hang over the MCU
I'm trying something different maybe you
should do the same
when we spends centuries as a mandarin
performing acts of terrorism within an
organization known as the Ten Rings
named after the 10 magical rings I gave
him his long life when Wu's son shangshi
came to reckon with his father's
exploits in adulthood he grappled with
his family's history and eventually
sought to stop his father once and for
all drawing the entirety of shanxi and
the legend of the ten rings when Wu was
painted as a criminal and a terrible
father to his children however as MTU
fans saw in the film when Wu mistakenly
believed his deceased wife was alive and
being held captive by the dweller in
darkness a creature best described as a
cross between a demon and a dragon this
delusion acted as when Woo's
justification for his wrongdoings so
what did it take for when Wu to realize
that his quest was a Fool's errand the
answer is his son in turn when Wu awoke
to his mistakes and repented sacrificing
his life to the monster while also
giving his son control over the powerful
Rings it was a powerful last minute
Redemption good with a long time villain
turning over a new Leaf hoping his final
Act can make up for a lifetime of pain
dad please
your family needs you
Laura Baza made her MCU debut in
Avengers Age of Ultron and the audience
learned that Hawkeye Had a Wife and Kids
who'd been keeping a secret or
performing his super heroic duties in
Ultron and some other minor appearances
there was little to suggest a character
was anything more than your average
ordinary one of the male superhero
spouse that is until the Disney plus
series Hawkeye in which Laura suddenly
seemed very invested in a Rolex watch
that Hawkeye was trying to track down we
were told that watch had connections to
its former owner's identity which could
be compromised if the watch fell into
the wrong hands or Kai succeeded in
procuring the watch whose owner was
revealed to be Laura herself and the
Kappa is that she's a former agent of
shield this plot twist presents a fun
Dynamic with which to revisit Laura's
appearances up to this point in
hindsight the character was keeping a
huge part of herself a secret looking
ahead to the Future IT presents exciting
opportunities to hopefully see her in
action
thank you from 2015 to 2019 Marvel
television created several shows for
Netflix that referenced events within
the MCU yet was seemingly unrelated to
Marvel Studios when Disney plus launched
in 2019 as Marvel Studios announced a
slate of shows for the new streaming
platform the Netflix partnership was
terminated and those stories and
characters seemed likely to be
narratively dismissed going forward even
so fans expressed their desire to see
the continuation of these versions of
Daredevil Jessica Jones and others after
a longer period of radio silence hope
emerged in December 2021 which saw the
sudden return of two beloved portrayals
in a big way first Kingpin appeared as a
villain in Hawkeye with Vincent
D'Onofrio reprising his role from the
Daredevil series that same month Charlie
Cox made a surprise appearance as Matt
Murdock in Spider-Man no way home even
after Daredevil's subsequent appearance
on She-Hulk details are still fuzzy as
to whether these are the same versions
of those characters answers from the
Netflix incarnations or with what fans
are seeing is in some sort of alternate
timeline nevertheless these are huge
Marvel characters so clearly they are a
necessary piece of the puzzle and it's
good to see the MCU won't be rolling the
dice with recastings
while the biggest reveal of Spider-Man
no way home was undoubtedly the return
of Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield as
their respective versions of Peter
Parker the film had even more tricks up
its sleeve one could argue that the
film's conclusion of Doctor Strange
wiping the world's memories of Peter
Parker will hold far longer lasting
repercussions in future MCU installments
than most people could imagine thanks to
a strange spell gone wrong individuals
from countless universes aware that
Peter Parker as Spider-Man were in the
process of being transported to the
mcu's primary timeline while that spell
could not be reversed his outcome could
be changed and saved Peter and his
friends from danger to save the timeline
from imploding Peter and strange devised
A desperate plan to rid the world's
memory of Peter Parker leaving the young
hero completely alone in the process it
was a juggernaut of an ending for an
already emotional story with the
touching nature of its final scenes
bringing a tragically beautiful
conclusion to this Spider-Man trilogy
foreign
early trailers for Doctor Strange and a
Multiverse of Madness seem to tease a
team up of sorts with Marvel sorcerer
Supreme under Scarlet witch embarking on
a mission together the ads also made it
seem like the film's plot would revolve
around the Fallout from Doctor Strange's
Multiverse tampering actions in
Spider-Man no way home as it turns out
both were misdirections to throw us off
the real story here MCU fans were
shocked when Dr Strange discovered
Wonder was in control of the very
monsters it sought out her support to
help him fight the sermon to gain access
to another reality in which he could be
a mother to her twin boys from One
Division the Scarlet Witch would suffer
nothing to achieve her heart's desire
with an incredible performance by
Elizabeth Olsen wonder and Multiverse of
Madness was a surprisingly Wicked and
Powerful antagonist
trailers for Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness hinted at the
film's inclusion of Heroes from across
the Multiverse and they appeared in the
form of the Illuminati a super group of
Marvel characters that's teased with an
audio clip in one of the movie's
trailers Patrick Stewart's version of
professor Charles Xavier seemingly from
the fox made X-Men films was among them
but he was hardly alone as it turns out
this Xavier was but one member of an
alternate reality super team known as
the Illuminati in addition to Professor
X the roster included Carl mordo Captain
Peggy Carter Maria Rambo Black Bolt and
Reed Richards nearly every character was
played by veteran Marvel actors for
turning to play variant versions of
their previous roles but Mr Fantastic as
portrayed by John Krasinski was fun
casting come true as Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige was happy to
indulge months of fans urging
krasinski's casting while the jury is
still out on whether Mr Fantastic will
look like Krasinski in the upcoming
Fantastic Four film reads brief moments
alongside the rest of the other eclectic
members of the Illuminati was a
thrilling tribute to Marvel media over
the years
in the first season of Loki the titular
character found himself with the
headquarters of the time variance
Authority the organization's mission was
seemingly to control the entire timeline
of the universe and Stamp Out any
variants which may occur going by the
motto for all time always the tvas
no-nonsense bureaucratic ways where hell
bent on maintaining the so-called sacred
timeline through a series of convoluted
explanations and Revelations MCU fans
learned that the TVA was seemingly
responsible for maintaining the
Integrity of existence itself with
mysterious figures known as the
timekeepers overseeing the whole
operation the audience would ultimately
have the rug pulled out from under them
however but Loki and Sylvie discovered
that the TVA was merely a false front
the tba's agents were unaware that the
timekeepers were robots and the Agents
had passed lives had been made to forget
the TVA and its stated purpose of
controlling the sacred timeline was an
elaborate lie hiding the actions
committed by he who remains better known
to Marvel fans as Kang the Conqueror he
disrupted time when multiple versions of
himself from other timelines tried to
interfere long ago and he created the
TVA to make his timeline the only
timeline there is more Kang to come in
future MCU projects but his initial
reveal was a plot twist disruption from
the aforementioned logic of Loki perhaps
laying the groundwork for future
misdeeds yet to come
the titular Heroes of eternals had a
long-held belief that they existed to
keep earth safe as it turned out they
were actually just conduits to prepare
Earth's inhabitants for extinction upon
the birth of a being known as a
Celestial as MCU fans discovered
alongside the film's characters they've
already done this countless times with
other planets but they just can't
remember what to the viewer was a mere
plot twist was to the characters the
disruption of their entire reason for
existing and their overall perception of
the world's existence now that they know
the truth the eternals go forward and
willing to continue his Pawns in a
scheme for the massive extermination of
all life forms on Earth instead they are
determined to challenge what's expected
of them and save the planet in doing so
like Loki the World building of eternals
was quite complicated and the
repercussions of its big gotcha moments
have yet to be fully understood
with phase 4's inclusion in the mcu's
Multiverse Saga opportunities have begun
presenting themselves for the occasional
cross-pollination of franchises Chief
among these seems to be X-Men alumni as
Evan Peters and Patrick Stewart were
both members of the Beloved Fox X-Men
movies and now have at least some
tangential place in the MCU however
Marvel Studios has yet to formally
establish the X-Men as part of the MCU
proper therefore a detail at the end of
the Ms Marvel series came as a huge
reveal perhaps setting up significant
repercussions to come early in the
series Kamala Khan inherited a powerful
bangle from her grandmother and
immediately gained superpowers making it
seem as though the power was derived
from the bangle itself but with help in
the scientific findings of her friend
Bruno Kamala would have come to learn
that the powers were within her genetic
structure All Along The Bangles simply
unlocked what had already been present
in the last episode's final moments
Bruno shared another layer of Discovery
explaining she possessed a mutation
while a music Q from X-Men the Animated
Series played in the background Kamala
there's something different
in your jeans
like
like a mutation
this was big news in an MCU that had
never said the word mutant before for
various reasons and was now seemingly
laying the foundation for the X-Men for
the first time Kamala Shrugged off the
news simply referring to it as a label
but could the Revelation possibly open
the door for X-Men to be more
prominently featured in the MCU going
forward as Stan Lee might say stay tuned
True Believers
foreign
[Music]